on soir philippe froguel merci d'être
avec nous en direct sur arte france est
une campagne de dépistage massif donc
qui s'annonce enfin me direz vous qui
prônez l'utilisation tous les tests à
savoir les pcr les antigénique les
salivaire oui c'est enfin assez
longtemps que qu'on demande ça enfin le
les pouvoirs publics ont pris une
décision et enfin il se décida à
travailler au plan logistique pour
rendre sa possible possible quand
peut-être à vendre à louer ou à courtrai
et fait donc dans trois endroits dont
deux pièces où il ya eu un énorme
circulation du virus le troisième le
havre je sais pas pourquoi ça a été
décidé mais enfin bon pourquoi pas et
donc voilà maintenant on commence à
travailler avec les pouvoirs publics et
au niveau local pour rendre sa possible
et surtout en tirer des conclusions
scientifiques et médicales pour la suite
puisque la suite c'est d'éviter une
troisième vague alors qu'on a bien vu
aujourd'hui que l'arrivée des vaccins
srl lente et très très progressive
est-ce qu'il n'aurait pas fallu faire
cela avant les fêtes alors pour la
plupart ça sera fait avant les fêtes
mais on n'a pas le sentiment que ça soit
vraiment l'objectif 1 vous venez de le
dire il faut éviter une troisième femme
mais pas forcément ce qui est si des se
sont pas forcément les fêtes de famille
de noël dans le nord par exemple ce sera
certainement après noël ce n'est pas un
petit peu dommage si on avait décidé 3
semaines avant et qu'on avait un plan de
près on aurait pu faire vers la mi
décembre mais là en tout cas dans le
nord ça paraît extrêmement difficile et
puis on a discuté entre nous et on s'est
dit que ce qu'il fallait c'était savoir
après les fêtes et la circulation du
virus qui va accompagner les personnes
où on en est exactement pour prendre les
bonnes mesures
maintenant ça n'empêche pas des
personnes qui vont voyager et voir leurs
parents aux grands parents d' de se
faire tester notamment les tests
antigénique sommes là pour savoir si ils
sont pas porteurs et protéger ainsi les
personnes qu'ils aiment donc campagne de
dépistage massive on l'a dit ipsr ans
qui gène ikke c'est l'hiver vous les
mettez tous au même niveau c'est est-ce
alors qu'on sait qu'ils n'ont pas la
même efficacité
les tests antigénique en efficacité plus
fait mais en plus il faut des
prélèvements naso fin grand legrand
coton tige
nous on aime bien les tests salivaires
qui s'emporte encore autorisée pour les
porteurs sains et lassé par la haute
autorité de la santé donc on va utiliser
ces tests grandeur nature dans ces
villes pour démontrer la haute autorité
de santé qu'on peut faire ça comme nous
fait d'ailleurs partout dans le monde
parce que les tests salivaires c'est
vous que plus facile
l'acceptabilité des tests salivaires et
de l'ordre de 90% alors qu'elle est plus
faible
ailleurs c'est important cette
acceptabilité parce que on aurait testé
tout le monde pas pas simplement une
toute petite fraction de la population
l'objectif vous disiez il faut éviter
une troisième vague
est ce que cette campagne peut-elle
vraiment éviter une troisième vague
parce qu'après évidemment il faut isoler
de manière efficace il faut qu'on essaye
de tout faire pour retarder cette
troisième vague qui si on fait rien
arrivera entre le mois de mars et le
mois de mai c'est à dire un moment où il
y aura très peu de personnes finalement
qu'en ont déjà été vaccinées en tout cas
parmi les gens qui bougent qu'ils
transmettent le virus et
et si on arrive à identifier le plus
possible des gens il conte maire met en
place enfin des mesures d'isolement
correct avec pouvoirs publics c'est à
dire en fête avec les collectivités
locales les services sociaux
on peut espérer comme dans d'autres pays
qu'on arrive à fortement diminué le
nombre de porteurs et donc espérer que
la troisième vague n'arrivera pas au
arrivera beaucoup plus faiblement et
plus tardivement à emmanuel macron a
prôné une contrainte dans l'isolation
ses débiteurs même parler d'éventuelles
sanctions vous vous êtes pour vous
pensez que c'est nécessaire moi je suis
je suis contre toute contrainte que ce
soit pour la vaccination que ce soit
pour le test isolement puisque ça
entraîne des débats à n'en plus finir
sur les libertés et finalement des des
activités contre-productive provocatrice
de toute une partie de la population
je préfère convaincre et dire à beaucoup
de gens que s'ils veulent revivre
normalement retourner au restaurant
aller dans les bars et dans les
night-clubs légime la salle de gym il
est vraiment important qui nous aident à
abaisser le taux de portage du virus la
fine il faut ballon a suivi tout à
l'heure l'allocution du premier ministre
vous disiez les vacances à risque
clairement de prendre du temps combien
de temps vous y croyez vous première
vaccinant vaccination fin décembre pour
les plus âgés en avril pour la plupart
de la population
moi j'ai vu ça comme un effet d'annonce
je pense qu'il y aura très peu de doses
qui vont arriver à la fin de l'année je
le pense aussi que on pourra au début
janvier février faire effectivement les
ehpad
tant mieux il y aura moins de personnes
qui vont mourir et moins qui se
retrouveront dans les hôpitaux mais
aujourd'hui tout le monde l'a dit il ya
dans les réanimations et dans les
hôpitaux il ya 40% de de gens qui ont
moins de 50 ans ce qui veut dire que
même s'ils ne meurent pas ils sont
vraiment malades
et si vraiment on veut s'en sortir il va
falloir il aurait fallu en réalité ça
des mieux se débrouiller
à voir le test files heures le test
moderna que les anglais vont avoir on
m'a déjà proposé imperial college de de
me faire vacciner dans les prochaines
semaines mais qu'en france on sait pas
débrouiller pour avoir rapidement
merci philippe froguel en tout cas
d'avoir été avec nous en direct sur rt
france merci à vous